just when you thought the Hollywood
sexual harassment scandals couldn't get
worse there's news about the latest
Hollywood creep actor Kevin Spacey a
close friend of Bill Clinton by the way
former child actor Corey Feldman has
been sounding the alarm about pedophilia
in Hollywood and now we're getting some
evidence that he may be right
last night BuzzFeed reported that Spacey
in 1986 made an unwanted sexual advance
towards fellow actor Anthony Rapp who
was at the time just 14 years old Spacey
released a statement on Twitter saying
he had no memory of the incident but if
it did happen he apologized for the
quote deeply inappropriate drunken
behavior deeply inappropriate behavior
drunken behavior we're talking about the
abuse of a child not throwing up on an
oriental rug in a desperate attempt to
justify his predatory behavior mister
Spacey on Twitter for the first time
confirmed the long-simmering rumors that
in fact he's a gay man well several
media outlets fast
fell for Spacey's trap and initially
focused just on his coming out one
abcnews.com headline read in part quote
Kevin Spacey comes out in emotional
tweet before it was changed to include
include Spacey's apology and the abuse
allegation frankly I don't care what
your sexual preference is no one gets a
pass when it comes to sexually targeting
a child let's be clear this isn't the
first nor will it be the last allegation
of underage abuse in Hollywood doesn't
matter how big a name the perp may have
and I'm glad Spacey's house of cards is
finally coming down